So He'd come back here where you see you at another case. Oh, in this early. Oh,
what is, what are those? Hairs are stride muscle. Oh,
that's muscle closest I can, the closest thing I can say is, uh,
the muscle dries out. So we get stringy and shredded. Okay. Where are we?
Let's actually, let's just start from the beginning. Okay. So, so we are in,
what, what room is this again? We're in this special procedures room. Okay.
Pima county office of the medical examiner.
And what we're looking at here is a case, uh, mostly skeletal remains.
So we have, uh, we have a skull, we have a few, we have some parts of the spine,
spine it looks like. And then just to add all three,
all three major bones of the lower limb. So the two, five bones,
the femurs and the two tibias and the to a fibrillate. We know,
we know it's the male, he's an adult. Okay. 20 to 30 to 40 year old, uh,
uh, migrant. It came in in late January,
early February and animals found him maybe 50% of his skeleton is missing his
upper limbs.
And his pelvis and most of his spine are missing in his hands and feet are
missing. We have evidence here that a vulture was feeding,
was feeding on the person. I don't know if this is,
it's a beetle that's a domestic beetle. It's called a hype beetle.
There they're found globally.
And these Hyde beetles specialize in eating dry hard tissue.
So He's, he's still leading. Yes, he is. Wow. He was in the body bag.
He and his colony would have been on the body wow. In the body bag. And, uh,
although we try to get most of them off during our exam,
you can see there's lots of little crevices where a single bug could, could be.
Wow. Oh, wow. That's so, yeah. Wow.
[inaudible]
I'm Chad. I'm Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And today we present the final episode of our border trilogy with Redis.
There's lots of Nasir and Tracy Hunt, and this is episode three,
which we're calling what remains.
Yeah. Okay. So just to catch everyone up, here's a lot of, uh,
the person I was just talking to, his name is Bruce Anderson.
He's a forensic anthropologist.
At the Pima County Office of the medical examiner in Arizona,
which is aware when they find a body of a unidentified migrant in the Sonoran
desert. That's where they bring them.
And Bruce had been working there, you know,
on and off since the 1980s.
But he told me that it was only in the early two thousands that he started
seeing, you know,
just more and more and more of these migrant bodies being brought in
and we're just crushed by the weight of all the dead and all the missing persons
reports and uh, you know, you're,
it's like working a mass disaster when people are still dying and planes are
still crashing around you and you,
you throw your hands up in the air sometimes and you just think once again to
stop
[inaudible]
and it hasn't stopped. The number of bodies found last year.
It was in the same range as the year before the number of people crossing.
It did go down after Donald Trump's inauguration,
but traffic is basically rebounded.
So people are still coming through the desert. They're not being deterred,
which made us wonder, is deterrence,
that fundamental idea behind our current border policy?
Is it even possible now? In some ways, that's a policy question,
which we talked about in our last episode, but it's also a human question.
Is Jason still there? I'm still here.
And that's what led us back to the person who we started this whole journey
with. The anthropologist Jason Deleon. All right. Can you hear lots of too?
I sure can't. Good morning. Oh, good morning. Fantastic. Well,
I feel like maybe we should just start off where we left off,
which is that you were going to tell us the story of, of Maricella.
Sure. Um, when was this, by the way? This would have been July,
June of 2012. Okay.
So we had been about two weeks into the pig experiment and this is a series of
experiments where Jason and his team, mostly students, uh,
looked at how pigs decompose in a desert in order to understand how people be
composed in the desert.
And it wasn't until about two weeks into this experiment where we were out
hiking one day with a group of about nine people down in southern Arizona.
And so on this particular day on this trail that I had hiked many, many times,
a student had run ahead to check stuff out and was taking pictures of us.
As we were walking up this hill,
he turns around, starts yelling at us, he says, Hey, you got to come up here.
Something has happened. So I threw my backpack down and at race up this hill.
And by the time I get up there, I see that,
that he's kind of staring at this body that's just laying face down in the,
in the dirt on this, on this trail. Like a fully intact body. Yeah.
A woman's body. You could tell it was a woman because she had long hair. Um,
you know, she's wearing camouflage clothes, stretch pants,
women's running shoes on. She's got a scrunchie around her wrist.
But the rest of it, I mean, her body was incredibly bloated.
I mean to the point where it looked like it was about to, um,
to pop from all of the gasses that had built up inside of her, her body cavity.
I didn't know what to do at this point. I mean, you know,
this student's start walking up. I mean, these are young students.
We had someone in the group who was 18, 19. For some of the students,
first time they've seen a dead body, one of them was crying.
I tell everyone, I say, hey look,
you got to go sit down and give me a second here to figure out what,
what it is we're going to do here. So first he called the police.
We did that and then we've kind of had a conversation,
are we going to photograph this person? Are we going to record any information?
Is this, are we still doing research right now?
And Jason decided, yeah, we should, we should document.
You know,
we took some notes down gray to green discoloration about what she was wearing,
brown to black discoloration of arms and legs. Took some pictures of the body,
her fingers. I've started to curl,
her ankles are swollen to the point that our sneakers seem ready to pop off.
There's a steady hissing of intestinal gases.
And then it just got to the point where I was like, okay, this is enough.
I don't want to do this anymore.
And so they covered her with a blanket because Jason noticed the birds circling
overhead for Turkey vultures.
And so at that point they just sort of sat down and waited for the police to
come. The sheriff, an hour went by, two, three, four,
just waiting with the body.
It was about five hours in that a sheriff and three border patrol agents show up
and they had hiked three miles to get to Jason with a stretcher.
And so they bring the stretcher, um,
the sheriff puts on gloves, he asks them a few questions like,
did you guys put the blanket on there?
And then they roll her into this white body bag. And as the authorities do that,
Jason, because she was faced down,
Jason gets to see her face for the first time.
And so he writes a paragraph in his book and it's pretty gruesome,
but I'm gonna, I'm gonna read to you the paragraph that he,
he writes about in his book as her body turns,
I see what is left of her face.
It is frightening and unrecognizable as human.
The mouth is a gnarled purple on a black hole.
Obscure red rest feature. These jurors,
I can't see her eyes because the mouth is too hard to look away from.
The skin around the lips is stretched out of shape as though it had been melted.
Her nose is smashed in and pushed up.
She died face down and the flesh on the front side of her skull has soften and
contorted to fit around the dirt and rocks beneath her.
The scene is a pastiche of metallic gray and Pea Green.
Whatever beauty in humanity that once existed in her face has been replaced by a
stone colored ghoul stuck in mid screen.
[inaudible]
it's a look you can never get away from. Yeah.
after this thing had happened and it really just shook me in a lot of different
ways. Jason says he just couldn't shake the question.
Who was this woman? How did she end up face down in the desert?
So that night I remember Jason Calling me, Jason called a friend of his,
a woman named Robin Ryan Nikki and being really clearly shaken and you know,
asking for advice, Robin actually runs this nonprofit in Tucson called
the Colibri Center for Human Rights Calibers Center for Human Rights.
And they do a lot of work with the missing and with bodies that had been
recovered. So Jason tells her, look, we've today we had this, this thing,
we found this person out here and could you help us id her.
Now the thing is,
Robin's office is actually in the medical examiner's office.
So that means that just down the hall from Robin is the Guy we met at the
beginning. Bruce Anderson, a couple hundred people,
or at least bones of a person are in here.
So Bruce is working on the medical examiners side.
So anytime an unidentified migrant body comes in,
Bruce tries to piece together who this person is looking at the dimensions in
the shape of the skull and markers, robustness of the bones.
I like looking at the length of the bones or the density of the bones by the non
fusion of these separate bones.
Looking at whether some bones in the body or fuse teams gather,
which is something that happens right after puberty.
Bruce can actually figure out approximately what age the person is, what gender,
height, weight. And in the case of the woman that Jason found,
her body was surprisingly in relatively good condition. So pretty quickly,
uh, they were able to determine, you know, she's probably in her thirties,
she's five foot before they were actually able to get fingerprints from her as
well. Meanwhile, on the other side, on Robin's side.
Wow. So each of these tabs is a person, is that right? Yeah,
she's dealing with hundreds of missing persons report all day. Every day.
She spends her days taking calls, going through voicemail
full of relative searching. I'm looking for my uncle.
He disappeared in 2010 or I'm looking for my daughter, she crossed, um,
two weeks ago. We haven't heard from her yet
and she's also getting tips from different people,
different aid organizations and it's actually one of those calls that leads to a
break in the case of the body that Jason found.
Huh. Okay.
So this is an email from me from 2012 hi Jason.
Just a quick update regarding the woman that your group found.
The case number is 12 1567 and as of yet she's not been identified.
Robin tells Jason that she got a call from an aid organization that had spoken
to a guy who had crossed the desert with a big group of people around the same
time and around the same area where Jason found the body.
He said that he had recently left behind to fellow travelers who were in serious
medical distress.
He's had, one of them was an elderly man,
70 years old and the other was a woman maybe from Guatemala or Ecuador,
late thirties early forties.
It isn't certain that this group is related to ml 1215, 67,
but it's highly likely I will contact Guatemalan and Ecuador and consulates
regarding new missing persons cases
and eventually using all the information that got gathered,
Robin was able to determine that the body that Jason found,
it's the body of a 31 year old Ecuadorian woman named [inaudible]
Maricela Aki Poi. Yeah.
Maricella Zag. We yes. Um,
Robin gets in touch with Jason and tell him Jason and asks her,
I would just would appreciate if you could, um, you know,
help me at all connect with this family.
Mm MM.
Does that request would oddly enough lead Jason to New York City.
That story in just a moment.
[inaudible]
Hey, it's me from Cincinnati, Ohio.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
jad Robert Radiolab.
We are back with the third installment of our border trilogy. What remains.
And when we left Jason,
along with Robin from the Kolibri Center had managed to id the body of the woman
he found in the desert.
And so now he was trying to get in touch with her family.
I don't know when people disappear when they die in the desert.
I think that the families make up lots of stories went through people's heads.
And so I was hoping that if I could find this person's family,
I could at least say, this is what it was like when we found her. Um,
this is what we think had happened.
So Robin was eventually able to get Jason to contact information for Marty
Stella's brother-in-law, who we'll call Fernando.
And I make the awkward phone call that says, Hey,
I'm the person that found mighty cell on the desert. Um,
and I would like to come and see you if that's possible.
Turns out Fernando actually lives in New York City,
but he had spoken to Maricella just before she left.
And when we heard his story, we decided, okay,
we've got to send a reporter Tracy Hunt. You're here to talk with him.
Oh yes.
I went to visit Fernando at his apartment in Queens.
He lives there with his three dogs, friendly guy, little shorter than neat,
neatly dressed. He's got, you know, dark hair longer on the top,
shorter on the sides. And
when I got there, he,
he pulled out a bunch of photos and Maddie Cela and molecule.
So this is their marriage, their wedding photos. Hey
[inaudible] she was his brother's wife.
They look so young where they 19 and again name [inaudible].
So in this picture that Fernando showing me, it's his brother and Marcella,
they're in a church and they're posing at the alter cheese in a white setting
gown and her hair is long and dark and shiny and she's got kind of like an oval
shaped face. And um, you know, she, she looks beautiful,
but even though it's her wedding day,
the thing that struck me is that she's not smiling,
not even a little bit is she, was he like, was she serious like that?
[inaudible] yeah,
actually that's part of the reason why my mother said she didn't like her as
much in the beginning. [inaudible]. She said,
you know, she always has an angry face zone.
She looks like somebody who doesn't have a lot
friends. And on top of that,
Fernando says she also had a habit of getting his brother in trouble.
[inaudible] you know,
she would tell my brother to sneak out of the house to go see her.
Last few years, I think dancing parties were permission, you know,
those kinds of things. But
[inaudible] she eventually won the family over. She helped out at home.
She treated my mom really well, especially his mother. [inaudible]
actually, I think my mother loved her more than she loved us.
[inaudible] Fernando's brother, they got married.
They ended up having three kids, two boys and a girl.
Marcella had a job in a factory that made kind of fit jeans,
I think Levi's and Fernando's brother.
He would go around to different villages selling sodas and they just kind of
really managed to make ends meet. They were living real rough at the time.
I mean going when I went to the house and saw where they had lived. So Jason,
after he connected with Fernando,
he actually ended up going down to Ecuador to meet Marcella's family before she
had left. I mean they were living in a one room plywood,
Shaq with a dirt floor and animals running,
running through the house and you know, and she had told her, her relatives,
she's like, look, my kids are literally starving here. So
[inaudible] at the time I wasn't able to help out as much financially because I
was also helping build a house for my parents where they were also going to go
live.
And so I wasn't able to support them as much or help out with things like school
[inaudible] and so, you know, which she really wanted to do, you know,
in order to like send your kids to school and all that.
She really wanted them to have,
which she never had to go new Canada cause she never had anything.
And so that was really the pressure that she was under.
So Fernando says in 2012 he called home
[inaudible] one time when I call home,
my mom said that she wanted to talk to me. So I said, okay.
Marisol got on the phone and she told me that she wanted to come here.
She told him that she and his brother, they want it to follow in his footsteps,
that if they could come to New York like he had, they could make money,
send it back home and help out their kids. But that was the only way.
And immediately Fernando was like [inaudible] no can, no can.
Absolutely not.
So Fernando told her no,
because he didn't want her to go through the same thing.
He went through 10 years before when I had gone to [inaudible] 2001 he was 17
years old.
I'm about to turn 18 and his aunt was about to go to New York and she convinced
him and his parents that if he went to New York, he'd be able to get a job,
make more money,
and support his family and from there have a better life to have things we
needed. So my father thought about it and gave his permission,
but he told not to stay here too long.
And so he used his grandfather's land as collateral and took out a loan for
$12,000 $12,000 yeah.
Do you know what the interest rate was on the loan? 10% 10% yeah.
So one thing that a lot of people have talked about is the fact that prevention
through deterrence,
it professionalized the human smuggling business because not only the,
these migraines need, you know,
guidance from all these south and Central American countries.
They also need guidance through the desert.
So now you have the smuggling business that's more expensive and also more
dangerous.
Oh No. [inaudible] yes.
So the [inaudible] told us that 15 days maximum to get here.
Fernando says he and his aunt took a bus from Ecuador to Peru and then from Peru
they flew to Panama.
And those are going to the [inaudible]?
No, got an another bus.
I is he into base eight equitable somewhere in Costa Rica.
I remember the path and really mountainous. There was river, all that.
This bus pulls over and the coyote who was with them at that point just said,
okay, you have to get off here. [inaudible] and [inaudible]. When we got out,
they took our luggage and they threw them on the ground towards the river and
they said,
you have to cross the river and someone will find you there and signal to that
person.
[inaudible] we were left there like that with my aunt saying, hold on.
That wasn't the deal. The deal was to take us all the way to Mexico and cars,
but from that point [inaudible] when we started crossing mountains on foot
[inaudible], that's when horrible things started to happen.
From that point on, they were packed into the trunks of taxis,
hidden and basements,
chicken coops and hut totally filled with rats and three months into this
journey,
a journey that was supposed to take just 15 days somewhere in Mexico.
Fernando says that he and his honor are taken to this rundown. Hacienda,
this just sprawling ranch house inside the ranch house.
IBM merged. They don't see it as in Quanta personas. I, yeah,
they were more than 250 people there at those babies have yet knows from all
over the world, 10 years Central Americans from every country,
from all over South America, America,
there's all these rooms filled with people.
And Fernando actually says that there were all these armed guards all over the
place.
Nobody was allowed to leave
[inaudible] and so we were um,
cause you miss instead of [inaudible] Penn in there for about a month, went into
[inaudible] [inaudible] some pedal. And while he was there,
this part I didn't tell Jason what happened to me there. I email,
I was on the [inaudible] main thing. I was abused sexually.
[inaudible]
Fernando says that he was sitting outside of the Hacienda when they,
with his aunt,
when a group of men approached him and told him that he had to go inside with
them. And he said no, that he was fine sitting there, you know,
outside
[inaudible] can only let me sit on another mic.
[inaudible] begged me to hurt them to please not abuse me or do anything to me.
And they said, no,
don't worry that that they only wanted to ask some questions inside,
but that that wasn't what they wanted.
They told Fernando, look,
you can come at this now or you can come at this later after we beat up your
aunts.
So finally Fernando relented and went with them and when they got inside the
Hacienda, they went into a room
[inaudible] and once we were inside [inaudible] I was out on the me.
He raped me three times
and Kamasi's like six
[inaudible]. After that I went to etomidate. I just wanted to die.
[inaudible]
after a couple of weeks,
Fernando and his od finally got out of this Hacienda and they start their trek
into the desert. Fernando,
things that he went through the same desert that Monticello would try to cross
10 years later,
he's actually caught by the border patrol and held for about a month before he
manages to bail himself out of detention and make his way to New York.
And Fernanda says he shared all of this with mighty Selah except his own rape.
But he did tell her that migrants do get raped. See that?
He's seen it happen that he knows it happens.
[inaudible] when I told her all of that,
she said none of that would happen to her.
She knew how to defend herself and you know if she had to, she would hit people
and then he told her you might have to go without food or asleep outside,
but
okay [inaudible] get that.
She said that didn't matter that all that mattered was getting here because the
kids are the ones that matter most.
Any sacrifice made is where worth they for your kids
and then he doesn't talk to her anymore. That's,
that's actually the last phone call they ever have because he thinks that if he
cuts her off, maybe she'll just give up.
But she goes to one of her brothers and her brother says that he would only pay
for her to go, but he's not going to pay for her husband to go.
When you found out that she was going to come by herself,
did you tie to tell your brother, look, she, he, she,
you shouldn't let her come here by yourself. Come at all. Sure.
See [inaudible] yeah. Yeah.
I called my brother said that there wasn't another option and that he wanted to
go first,
but her brother had put the condition that she go first and because they didn't
have another option. She said she would go
in May of 2012 Maddie cellar left Ecuador about three weeks later.
Right before she walked into the desert.
Marisella sent her family a message on Facebook. She told them,
I don't know how I'm going to get there, but I am going for my family.
God willing, I will get there.
When did you finally hear that actually happened to her? A
[inaudible]. Someone called me. Yeah,
I knew you told me they were from the consulate and I said, okay.
Finally she's been found and then they told me you're the UK.
[inaudible] was dead and they didn't know what they exactly,
she died with that she'd been dead for about a month except
[inaudible]. It was just really
difficult. Wondering if I'm going to do more damage than, than good bye.
Bye Bye bye. Calling to meet these folks.
Eight months after Marcel is death.
Jason came to New York to meet Fernando and he brought with him the pictures of
Marcel, his body that he took when he, when he found her in the desert,
you know,
he was like just right now show me the photos and I was just dancing around that
for for over an hour.
[inaudible] and Jason warned that the photos were really upsetting.
It was so many like that,
but I said that it's okay to show them to me and I give him this book of photos
that I've printed out and it's got pictures of this shrine that we built for her
in the desert.
It's got pictures of my students who were there and then eventually it's just
pictures of like the back of her head. So it's her hair,
it's some of the clothing is hits her hand.
[inaudible] I saw all the photos and the truth is that it told me two pieces to
see or imagine everything she had to endure in the desert.
[inaudible].
She tried to keep going, dragging herself a
[inaudible] brought me photos of how she was found in her body outstretched,
trying to keep going.
[inaudible]
before Mary cell, his body was sent back to Ecuador.
Fernanda decided they should have it sent to New York. First
don't say is, I'm say you're
[inaudible] so when I talk to my family, I said, you know,
her dream was really to arrive here and so I thought at least we can fulfill
that dream with her body by your
[inaudible] to be able to have to have a wake for her here.
They held awake at a funeral home in Queens.
Almost a hundred family members and friends came to celebrate Marcella's life.
They were told to keep the coffin shut.
The next day
her body went back to Ecuador.
Fernando had to stay in New York because he knows if he were to go back to
Ecuador, it would just be way too hard to try to come back to the United States.
He says that, you know, right now he's just trying to fulfill a promise
[inaudible] promise that I made to Marcella's body when it arrived here that I
was going to look after her children.
I was going to try to give them what she had wanted for them.
When you think about that conversation,
do you think that there's anything you could've said that would have made her
stay
[inaudible] told her what could happen along the way?
[inaudible] I thought that would be a way of deterring her.
[inaudible] no, no, no.
A
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and it's worth pointing out. Uh, you know,
I mean more generally prevention through deterrence as a, as a, as a strategy.
It hasn't deterred people from coming to the u s either. Uh,
the annual budget for the border patrol is roughly three point $5 billion bigger
than it was in 1990 we have about five times as many border patrol agents and
yet the number of pupil immigrants living here,
undocumented has more than tripled during that time from three and a half
million to a body.
11 million and more people are coming every year, every day.
And more people are dying along the way.
[inaudible]
yeah, look, we'll do it here. About a year after Maricella
died, Jason got a call from her family
again. Do you want, um, do you want maverick or iceman? Yep.
And get the name of the drones guys are top gun thing.
Another family member had disappeared in pretty much the same place Maricella
did.
So which is this? I think that's, that's maverick Navarik I'm going back to the,
to the Arizona desert basically because Marcella has a, um,
had a cousin who,
a 15 year old cousin named Jose [inaudible] who disappeared almost one year to
the day that she died.
[inaudible]
um, I was able to kind of triangulate based on interviews with people who he was
with and with information from, um,
from various folks where we think he went missing. I mean,
I told his mom that I would not stop looking and um,
it took me a couple of years to figure out a, to, to, to, to do that.
Um, but right now it's, we'll go back and we'll use these drones and,
and see what we can come up with.
[inaudible]
and you know better than anyone who, what happens to bodies in the desert now?
I think, I mean,
why are you still looking for him or why, you know? Yeah,
as callous as that question sounds. I guess for me,
part of it is I just don't know what else to do. If you feel so hopeless.
I told his mom like, I won't, I won't stop looking for him.
I'll do whatever I can, whatever little thing that I can do.
And if I can't find him, well maybe I'll find somebody else
[inaudible]
mad at me now. So we will was,
it's getting mad at me cause it's run out of batteries.
Well do you want to do one more?
One more line?
[inaudible] immigration. Yeah.
Poses real problems and challenges and is always provides great opportunities
for the American people. Boy, you a male
[inaudible] we're 40% of the babies born on Medicaid.
Four year old was driving like on from testify based on my chance amendment
constitutional right line and the advice of counsel I with my Fifth Amendment.
You like American
[inaudible] city
[inaudible] national rights [inaudible] agent Dale Music aide.
That was about 40 skills to divide.
[inaudible] can't just arbitrarily stop you just because of the cost.
The real ran into try to remain tight. Apprehended
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Well,
this episode was reported by Latif Nasser and Tracy hunt produced by back kilty
and Tracy Hunt. Jason Delhi owns book,
which inspired the series is called the land of open graves.
Special thanks to our interpreter Alison Corbett and for giving voice to
Fernando in English. Got [inaudible] and Carlos Manager, Ken Brunson.
Thanks also to Hayden Stewart, Raul Rasp, astronomer Paulina,
Alonzo Chavez and ambassador Jacob Prado from the government of Mexico and to
the staff at the Pima county medical examiner's office and the [inaudible]
center for human rights. I'm Jana [inaudible]. I remember cribbage.
Thanks for listening.